Bobby what are some mistakes she made
early on coming here and in your career
that you wish you hadn't or that weren't
maybe horrible mistakes but there was
something that had you known you
wouldn't have done whether it's just
spending too much time thinking about
this or whatever it is yeah okay
there was one of my early jobs was on
Fantasy Island and I was among a retinue
of young women you know that were
surrounding this older man who was the
star the guest star of the show and so
we broke for lunch and one of the other
women I had lines this other woman
didn't have lines but she we were
walking to lunch and she was a goddess I
mean she was so beautiful and very sweet
and really lovely and we were just
talking and I liked her right away and
then she started to tell me about her
husband and immediately I got this
overwhelming sense of dread on her
behalf I mean I have chills now even
remembering it and he had she'd been
working at a Dairy Queen in Canada or
something and and he's he was older than
she and he spotted her and he saw what
she was and he got her into Playboy and
she had a you know Playboy centerfold
spot and and she and the more she talked
about him
the creepier I felt about this guy but
you know we just met each other what am
I going to say about her husband you
know you better watch out for him and
and then I learned that she was with my
agency and then about a week or a month
later two months later maybe I'm walking
with my agent to an audition and he
tells me that this woman just got a part
in a major motion picture now I have
been classically trained actor since I
was two years old and she had just blown
into town now she was a goddess I have
to give you that in Hollywood you know
eats that up but I was so jealous I
couldn't believe it I was just churning
with envy inside and
and and it would oh it felt like it was
awful and about two months after that I
was going to New York I had a play that
I was taking to New York that I wanted
to shop around a bit and I'm walking
home and I see a headline you know
beauty queen slain and I thought it was
some you know Miss New Jersey or
something I didn't pay any attention I
called my agents to find out what was
going on if I should come home early
they said oh we're just so worried it
were just so upset about Dorothy and I
put on my best best I tried my best to
care and I went oh really
why and she said didn't you hear her
husband just shot her in the face and
murdered her because she was drifting
away from him and it was Dorothy
stratten who was the subject of the film
star 80 and even how you see that the I
was so ashamed of myself for begrudging
her one moment of celebrity or joy
because I had no idea what lay before
her and I had no idea what she went
through to get that to get there to to
her moment in the Sun and how dare I how
dare I
and that was I was more affected by what
what by her death and what it called up
in me then I was on my own grandfather
because I was so ashamed of my jealousy
do you know I was going to bring that
story up as you started to tell me and I
have no I mean I was right now I did not
even know you were gonna go there I was
going to bring up the Dorothy stratten
oh my god were you so it I just like so
I mean I have chills right now because I
was gonna talk about that Wow I didn't
even know you so when I said the word
Dorothy you went lady yeah I would have
chills right now well that was one of
the biggest mistakes I ever made and boy
did it changed me yeah I remember seeing
them
and and yeah that's it's it's very sad
she was such a lovely girl she was such
a genuinely sweet person you know yeah I
I didn't know her but I mean she wasn't
a climber she took advantage of the
opportunities that came to her and and
so she should have been so would we all
right we all were not the thing yeah and
a little bitter part of me was I just
couldn't well and I think to as younger
women were trained to be competitive in
some sense or maybe this town I know we
talked about yes yes the culture the
culture of the town so I think it's
unfortunately somewhat normal as
especially you know being in grade
school you know you can just remember
feeling the same way towards someone and
I think being honest enough to talk
about I know Marc Maron has always
bashed for his talking about how he was
jealous of something and actually think
it's healthy that he's able to admit
that when I think a lot of people feel
it so right you just happen to have an
experience that is so powerful because
most don't end up that way and then
right wow I I was gonna literally bring
that up mind meld
yeah Wow and for anyone that doesn't
know the Dorothy stratten story I
encourage them to look it up just as a
way to just little primer right what can
happen yeah yeah and just again
comparing outside right to or other
people's outsides to our insides and
especially in this town and we never
know right and when I said about a
primer about what can happen I don't
mean the result of what happened to her
but I just mean what can happen to you
as when you resent and and bear jealousy
and envy towards someone who has nothing
at all to do with you or your life or
your trajectory in this life yeah and I
think as time goes on and we go out for
things whatever our chosen pursuit is
and we don't get them and we see other
people get them it's just natural
it's going to happen and we're going to
feel upset and I think it's just to
cycle through it and be like okay I feel
it and now I'm gonna let it go to
exactly feel it I mean it's inhuman not
to feel it you have to feel it but we
don't have to live in it you know feel
it be disappointed it's disappointing
right but you live to two bats
another day you know Wow yeah that's
quite a story story thank you
you